what do homeschoolers do at 8:00am
they make their own breakfast
of course that's a lie
normally they're still asleep
but for some reason
my kids got up at 7:00am this morning and we're ready for breakfast
by last year I gave them the responsibility of getting their own breakfast
I do snacks lunch
dinner all of things they can get their own breakfast in
my daughter Learned how to make eggs
and then we always have easy breakfast things on hand like cereal muffins
bananas yoghurts
those types of things
but this morning they wanted to learn how to make scrambled pancakes
so Mama had to
usually only have to help them two or three times
before they can do it on their own
this has really saved me as a homeschool mom
because so much of their day to day responsibilities fall on
and this has been an easy way for me to have a slow and quiet morning
and they have some responsibility for this
but this didn't just happen overnight
it took a lot of time and practice of learning things in the kitchen
but also learning about food that feels their body
because we all know that when mom is not on top of it
they are gonna grab the sugary treats and all of the junk
so for one we just don't buy that stuff
so it's not a temptation and 2
I taught them about proteins and fats and nutrients
and all the things that make our bodies feel good
most of us who grew up in the 90s and early 2
surrounded by diet culture
have a bad relationship with food
and that's not something I want my kids to ever experience
and even now we're learning so much about all of this crap that's in our food
and how it's all bad for us
but that is a conversation for another
we put a huge emphasis on fruits
veggies and animal products in our house
and that's just naturally what our kids go
I have no idea how I got down that rabbit hole
but I just hope that you all have a fantastic Wednesday